welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on Earth and human
management of our microbial wealth it's
my pleasure to introduce to you dr. John
Thomas professor emeritus at West
Virginia University School of Medicine
dr. Thomas is recognized as an
international educator a global
microbiologist having lectured in more
than 43 countries as a clinical
microbiologist in pathology clinical
professor in dentistry and an adjunct
professor in graduate school education
for 54 years his translational research
emphasized biofilms and medical devices
dr. Thomas has over 50 publications and
multiple book chapters spanning his
career for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the byberry tab at
the top of your screen dr. Thomas's
keynote presentation is titled microbial
centric aging a paradigm shift
my name is Michelle Ashton and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
blabbers is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the play
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab on the top right hand corner
of the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credits
now without further ado please join me
in low dr. John Thomas I will now turn
the presentation over to him
well thank you very much Michelle and
it's really my privilege and part of my
my psyche to want to continue to educate
even I think when some of us have
decided to be to be retired and go on in
the academic world - the actual
classroom but what I want to do today is
is go with you and hopefully create in
your mind some of the enthusiasm that
I'm developing
with a topic of aging it's somewhat
topical to me but it also clearly
identifies an area where we have much to
learn the world and where we're
beginning to learn that maybe the
microbes are much more important than
we've ever anticipated in my lecturing
capacity at West Virginia University I
developed a a cadre of cadets and
puppets you'll see them listed here my
puppets help me create a theme and so if
you get a chance one of the things I
want you to do is to see the website
which is global bugs dot-com which under
certain categories in this case teaching
will describe the importance of these
puppets and their relative
teams to the lecture material that we're
going with today I won't use everyone I
will use selected ones but I want you to
realize that this is all part of who we
are and the theme that I want you to
address is again going to the website
something I began to think about and
that is we need to rethink microbiology
and I came up with an advertisement that
sort of addresses that interest and I
call that microbiology reimagined and on
the website there are actually five keys
of what this new microbiology reimagined
is and one of them clearly is what we
will talk about today is that is aging
and the concept that we need to deal
about wellness we need to recognize that
there are multiple parts and who we are
as far as our wellness our earth and the
animals around us and in all I want you
to carry the theme that says we live in
a microbial world
this is the website specifically you'll
notice in the lower right hand corner I
have the Center for homo genomics
clinical studies and that really
addresses the theme of who we are
relative to our microbial inhabitants
are
microbial ajik kin and there's quite a
bit of material here that helps
supplement what I'm going to be talking
about so please do at the moment you
have some time go to the slide because
it will have supplemental information
that enhances I hope the lecture today
and as I already said to you one of the
key points is that as addressed by two
previous presidents of the American
Society for Microbiology
we need to deal with one health one
wellness and it addresses three things
the globe animals and the inhabitants
you and I Homo sapiens and it expands if
you look at the slide on the bottom
features that we need to consider when
we address who we are who contributes to
who we are and the wellness that each of
those parts will play
if you think of it as a genetic scenario
and you look at how we interact gene
wise there's often the discussion that
the globe provides us through a variety
of mechanisms some information that is
transferred and that ultimately impacts
on Homo sapiens it's slow it takes
millennium evolution one of the thoughts
I hope to generate in your mind is that
if you address the impact of a genetic
information provided by microbes it
could be fast it could allow us to in
fact not alter this theme of evolution
but clearly make it a theme which has an
impact in our lifetimes so keep that in
mind
as we go through this this is my first
real thought on Aging and I'm going to
address a definition because that's
clearly something that's always part of
a of a new topic we need to be
considering about who aging applies to
and the magical year of 2035 will
explain to wise I go on
that slide is now we in the United
States as a representative of the globe
our an aging nation and in 2035 over 50%
of our population will be 65 or over
that's incredibly important because as
you see in the globe using some of the
more recent Japanese data we've always
addressed on the left hand side sort of
the pyramid which is changing in 205 and
the forecast for 255 on a global
perspective addresses another key
feature here that the female and male
propensity to be equal in all things is
not quite true and this has an important
point on longevity and aging because
look at the concept of who lives longer
and is there a reason for that which is
genetic and if so can we alter it by
using certain information based genetics
which could be microbes so think about
that as we develop this theme
the idea of classifying Aging and
biologic aging as a disease has been
around it's not new but it gains stature
when people began to really give it some
thought relative to how it impacts our
costs and how it addresses research so
aging originally has been advised as a
harmful abnormality of bodily structure
and function and it may has some
specific causes which I'll elaborate on
a moment but what are the benefits if we
suddenly describe aging as a disease we
eliminate this sort of fatalism and we
suddenly say there is something to be
gained by recognizing its importance as
a disease and in the read at the last
paragraph it talks about would we begin
to address more Jarriel protective drugs
regenerative medicine
precision medicine would we enhance
grants support to address aging as a
disease and would we gain access to a
better understanding of ace aging as a
specific feature
it really began to a facilitate world
opinion in 2015 when in Brussels that
big it was a major meeting and they said
look it it's time to classify biologic
aging as a disease in 16 2016 it gained
more editorial support when they said we
need to address the academic
pharmaceutical and healthcare policies
relative to pensions and funding
perspectives the us again a little bit
slower began to address this after
appeared in a a meeting in Ghent and
where the NIH said you know there may be
a real reason to address the
International theme and it's time to
classify aging as a disease and really
interesting a consequence of
evolutionary neglect not evolutionary
intent and there's a lot of information
about that and it has gained its
x-naught acceptance but notoriety
because there are those who clearly feel
that this is not the way to go and
that's one of the interesting things
about it because this is a controversial
subject and though is that opinioned had
the opposite side refuted the arguments
describing aging as inevitable aging
cannot be avoided and so there are very
real opinions that have significant
distinct thoughts those who agree with
the theme that aging cannot be defined
as a disease often address a diagram
such as the one seen in front of you
which on the left-hand side many lists
some of those
unclassified but yet important features
of aging lost some regenerative ability
loss of cell proliferation in contrast
to those that are clearly associated
with disease on the right hand side
cancer arterial sclerosis
myocardial infarction and so how do you
relate these two themes and yet still
not just hinder the development of what
I think is an incredibly important
feature
and of course as I'm going to explain to
you in a moment if you look at who we
are and who is with us through evolution
of
with sapiens
where do the microbes fit are they the
elephant in the room is there a missing
link here to age and age-related disease
which could be shepherd by microbes
unless gardener in 2016 wrote a
marvelous editorial it said to ignore
the genetic impact of our dual citizens
is to miss the point
you cannot put them in a can and have
them go away so the bottom line is is
you'll see my impression is that we need
to readjust this feature and we need to
put it in a perspective that allows us
to gain access to more data and that's
why we met perhaps need to address it as
a disease anyway moving forward let's go
to section three here I have three of my
puppets the one on the upper right-hand
corner is one that deals with age the
other aspect is one that deals on the
middle right-hand side with
planktonic microbes and then we've got
Marco Polo a game that I remember we all
played and I'll tell you why this is
important because we're going to talk
about the evolution of the whole of
genomic theory we're going to talk about
as I mentioned our biologic in
recognizing that microbes matter and at
the end of this section begin to address
can we get more information and data
relative to who the players are in this
disease perhaps that we call aging by
the genetic tools that are now on the
market and I'm going to hopefully expand
that theme as we address this whole idea
of the whole of genomic theory the whole
of Geneva theory has been around for a
while as I'll show in a moment in a
slide but in essence in a diagram it
points out that the history of evolution
involves both humans in the green on the
left-hand side and microbes in the blue
on the left-hand side and they are often
described as evolutionary paths parallel
but not integrated the reality is on the
diagram to the right but in fact we have
evolved together I like to call it
intelligent symbiosis
they are our biologic in our dual
citizenship is passport directed for
both those microbes and the human cells
that make up who we are
this is perhaps better explained here
because part of the whole large anemic
theory is I'll again explain in a moment
addresses the host genome the genetic
information of our hosts plus the
microbial gene pool both called as one
the Hollow genome with the whole genomic
theory certainly as we talk about the
globe and what it means with animals and
our partners in the globe all contribute
to the gene strength of Homo sapiens but
to avoid aging as a discussion when the
only discussions about the host genome
and not the microbial genome or the
micro holo biocked is probably incorrect
so if you see in the next slide and I
have Marco Polo remember as kids we used
to play the game Marco Polo there's two
parts to that discussion and
basically the whole genomic Theory
brought to fruition and a national
attention at Woods Hole in 1989 said
that look it there's two parts to us
there's a dual partnership but we're
going to call us the whole of biome
there is a macro which is the gene
strength of Homo sapiens and there's the
micro which is the gene strength of the
microbial population that is evolved
with us in parallel and the whole of
biomes particularly in the microbial
sense has has the option of doing three
things we can amplify what the microbes
do we can bring in novel strains from
the environment and we can have
horizontal gene transfer all addressing
the micro polar boya which is part of
our dual citizenship in our biologic kin
Marco Polo
if you look at it in another perspective
look at the gene strength it is I'm
gonna point out to you in one case we
had 10 trillion cells with the macro
hollow pilot and we have over 100
trillion cells with the microbiome and
that Nobel Prize winner has described
the gene is one of the three most
important features of discovery in the
19th and 20th century the reactive the
bottom line is that we need to recognize
these two work together and that it's
important that is in the issue they do
have the feature is shown by the
movement here that together we are a
different perhaps perspective of who we
are recognizing that microbes matter
very much microbes matter
if you want to go and become very
scientific on this point we can do so by
looking at the gene strength that we
just described the whole of violence of
the macro combination on the left and
the Kolob island of the micro
environment on the right and if you look
at the numbers of genes that we have as
far as homo sapien about 23,000
approximately these numbers vary but
approximately if you look at the number
of genes that are involved with our
micro polar violence that microbial
next-of-kin you've got about three
hundred sixteen thousand genes and that
number continually evolves and as i've
said to my students it's really we the
human we have in textbooks maybe one
book of information genetically the
microbes have perhaps
316 war that's the number that we talk
about and the reality is if you take
this as a theme you can begin to address
why cannot be a feature of aging that
does not include some concept of the
impact of the genetic strength of our
other equal partner who is and has
evolved with us over time that's the
whole of genomic theory it really in
ways I've said to students all my life
it really is a
anti-clock
and even though we passed your theme on
the both of those melt with more
pathogens and put the microbes at a
rather relatively disadvantages they did
disadvantage point the bottom line is we
needed to really play a more significant
assessment of their benefit and not
benefit to who we are
one of the thoughts then is as this
whole hold you know what theory has
evolved it's been supported by the new
evolution of diagnostic procedures in
the laboratory and as you see in the
center of the diagram is a tree which
sort of highlights phyla but highlights
the relationship of microbes as defined
now with some of our new rapid DNA
testing and if you look at the outline
on the left hand side at lists life in
our taxonomy
we have over five to ten thousand
species and Homo sapiens we have a huge
array of microbes in the genus up to two
thousand and the bottom line is how does
a diagnostic laboratory of which I was a
director for years I begin to address
this whole concept so it's beginning to
be a pair that there are really in the
taxonomy of the organisms that are part
of our system perhaps ten that are
critical sixth are really important and
become benchmarks of health and disease
and they are listed there for you the
asset in Oh bacterial the vector
entities the firm acute Eames the
proteobacteria the cyanobacteria and the
fuser bacteria those are phyla it gives
us the chance of looking at ratios of
not just five to ten thousand species
which would be incredibly difficult even
with artificial intelligence but it
begins to give us a theme of who are the
major groups that are within our system
and how do we address them relative to
health and disease in this new outline
of the whole dynamic theory
now one of the points that obviously we
need to address
is if you look at the organisms I and
the phyla which I just listed for you in
the diagram and slide before and you
look at sort of a a schematic of age you
begin to get a visualization of how
these phyla change now certainly we
could look at species within the phyla
and certainly on individual studies to
get a better handle on who the players
are but in getting the concept and
beginning to measure changes of who are
Co habitants are over time this is the
way it allows us and if one thing that
allows us to perform we can measure
phyla and we can measure them over time
and the new tools allow us to do so
particularly rapidly
which it brings us to the point of DNA
testing a
lot of the newness of DNA testing is as
I'll mention a moment related on
ancestry but in development of a test
that looks at the micro holo by on and
the whole of genomic Theory there are
now several online
procedures test centers which allow us
to look at the microbial contribution so
that we can get both the macro hold of
lions and the micro hold of lions in a
reasonable time frame and its
implication in not only health wellness
but disease so the one that at the
moment I have been using it uses machine
learning it's the new biome it's not the
only one it's probably been the one on
the market the longest it uses advanced
intelligence statistical analysis and it
allows us to look at a sample which
obviously all of us have talked about
the second brain if you will or the
combination of phyla within stool
samples and the offering at the moment
is that you can do a a single sample or
you can do a time-lapse which allows you
to overtime with changes in what you are
doing together not the DNA information
of your hosts that is the macro whole
violent but the micro coulomb ion and it
gives you at this moment a diversity
score a percentile of what viola and
organisms might be at proportion to
those that have other characteristics
similar to your own
they develop that adversity score as I
mentioned I'm hopeful that we get more
information as time goes on but they
have a learning center as do most and
the list of publications which will give
you again the concept that within
multiple avenues now we have the ability
to measure the micro hull of ion which
is part of the hollow genome
well what about the macro hollow buoyant
or the hollow genome of our other
partner and obviously there are a
variety of tests online and rest
ancestry.com
23andme new ones appear on Facebook
invariably daily and all of them
basically ìletís established our family
history they allow us to link to a tree
and maybe get some records they are
getting a little more sophisticated
establishing some health risks and
traits I have some concerns about this
but it's all part of the whole idea that
if we can define aging as a disease and
make us part of wellness both from the
microbial perspective and from our
genetic host perspective we will really
begin to get a handle on how these two
interface and how they are good and bad
in aging particularly more recently as
you probably also know there's quite a
number of tests appearing again on
Facebook and other social media sites
those that will take your data and
decipher it and so you can send them
your ancestry.com or 23andme or nebula
genomics or whatever they will give you
back information that is beyond what the
scope of the initial testing was able to
provide or they will provide you
information that is is linked to not
only your history but some some disease
parameters I'm going to caution you
about this we'll talk about this at the
conclusion and but there's still so much
to be learned I think there is a rush to
look at this data but the fact is if we
make disease and aging a part of the
scheme that is NIH recognized is funded
by research particularly pharmaceutical
houses we will begin to have a means and
a reason to look at these two combined
together the micro coulomb Island and
the macro holo biome
well having spent some time doing that
and now that you know who you are and
now that we know why it's important to
recognize two parts of yourself and that
this self is part of the globe which can
be influenced slowly through revolution
or rapidly through time with microbial
impact let's look at the theories of
aging and let's look at a way that I
brought to fruition with my puppets but
try to give students an idea of how
important this whole idea of who we are
relative to our cohabitants early in
life
so first of all what are the theories of
aging what is the idea of a microbial
clock and a biologic clock but what are
some of the common pathways in an
age-related diseases if aging is a
disease how does the related diseases
play into this and
specifically how do our gut brain
interface occur again developing the
theme of the macro whole of my own and
the micro full of volume so let's take a
look at that
I'm gonna be using again some of my
puppets but the theme addresses what I
mentioned early on and that is that we
have genetics who we are we have the
globe who provides animals environment
of who we are and historically most
theories of Aging addressed either a
genetic component an environmental
component or as listed by number three
a combination of both
genetic environmental then accommodation
of both rather simplistic but
nonetheless sort of easy for
categorizing where things go and only
until recently did anybody begin to
think about where where does this
category go with microbes and that's
what we're now beginning to address
so there are a huge
reference weet there is a lot of
references and a lot of articles that
written about human aging and how cells
and components of the cells particularly
are affected by a variety of things some
of them are listed here just some that
literature is replete textbooks are
replete you know damage and loss of
damage control
cross linking within brain cells build
of an amyloid between cells
failing in adaptive immunity and the
list goes on microbial DNA damage
nuclear DNA damage buildup of since
essence cells all of those addressed
what has historically focused on one
aspect of our genetic strength and that
has been the mackerel Hollow biome so
the issue that I want to address and
then I hope to stimulate your interest
in its then where do the microbes fit in
if there is such a reality as a homo
biown and we have a hold of genome we
can't ignore microbes and how can they
fit in
so as I began to address this topic of
interest to me about 10 years ago I
began to really think about this I'm an
avid runner and I when I run I take a
pad and I can jot down notes it's a time
when my mind begins the really function
as a as a as a scientist as well as a
runner and I began to be apparent that
hey we we as humans can be classified
sort of in for age groups it's also easy
to find data on these for age groups and
that we could look at young adolescents
the midlife and then the aged person and
we could also find information about the
cost because
in fact as you see here written in red
32% of all medical costs are spent in
the last two years of life
if that's true is it which is and if
it's part of who we are can we make a
picture that will relate to the other
side of this diagram and that is who we
are relative to a clock and our
microbial composition as it changes with
time
so what I envisioned to help again
translate for audiences like you and the
idea of teaching about the microbial
clock is if you look at diseases of
which I chose 10 again based on cost and
you divided them into a young green
which addressed those things listed
there autism asthma particularly mother
in newborns and we call this thing
infant microbiota
who are the players if you look at phyla
then we want to addressed of those six
which ones are key at this stage the
other side if you look at adolescents
and you look at diseases like diabetes
and obesity again who are the players in
the phyla who are the microbial micro
pol or ions that have a feature involved
in this if you look at then adolescent
the orange part of the diagram you can
look at other parts of the disease
process meaning with gut particularly
irritable bowel disease
gastrointestinal diseases but what about
vaginal diseases osteoporosis and then
you look at who those diseases on and
population which by definition is
addressed as agent as it's fifty five
statistically but a lot of us have
addressed this at 65 and over what about
the microbiota of an agent individual
particularly those that are in nursing
homes dementia
Alzheimer's disease who are the players
in this environment
and my theme here was really also driven
by a person I've had the experience of
talking to and working break free
at a distance is the Martin Blaser
connecting multiple diseases through a
single framework or underlying cause was
his theme and I've sort of taken that
theme and applied it to the microbiota
that we are part with in our Homo Sapien
relationship and said how can I show
this in an environment which allows me
to say to the audience your microbiota
changes with time which we all know it
can be measured in a time and it's part
of who we are
so if you look at the literature and I
started to do that with great deal of
enthusiasm
and you look at the concept of those
four categories of green yellow orange
and red and you look at the individual
phyla which are involved one can begin
to look at diseases in those age groups
and with the newer molecular
microbiology begin to assess the
prevalence of certain violà certain
species that are found pre-eminently in
those diseases now is there cause and
effect that's still to be proven but the
reality is we are in continual revolving
cycle of microbes in our lifestyle they
can be measured now and they certainly
can be addressed in a particular disease
process
what really made this more important and
where we are going is not only then the
microbes as part of our phyla it is
brought on by micro hollow violent but
what are those micros in combination
with other microbes at the particular
disease and the age of the individual
what do they have in common as they
function what are these viola at a
particular age group doing
functionality-wise do these microbes
involve themselves in a particular
capacity of protein metabolism
carbohydrate metabolism
energy metabolism or lipid metabolism
just to begin to address a few so not
only can we begin to look at who's
present at what disease state in what
proportion to the other phylum we can
begin to measure their function that
they at that age group with other
microbes begin to alter or enhance and
does this help us and better clarifying
disease state if we have a common
pathway dr. Blaser so well described
particularly now as this lecture is
addressing aging and the agent
microbiota what we need to do is begin
to look at those aging diseases as again
a potential clarification of disease and
look at them not only as what I just
addressed but functionality but what
about another key category which is what
about those that we lose over time as
I'll show in a minute we lose an awful
lot and change a lot in this globe and
we change a lot about who our symbiotic
organisms are so that not only do we
need to be thinking about what organisms
are present in what functions they
provide relative to energy metabolism in
particularly gut location but what ones
are missing with time because if we can
address missing as well as present
perhaps we haven't alternative to
therapy and as we go through this I hope
you'll remember that there are four age
groups that were sort of selected
because they enhance the ability to
educate to describe and to relate but
it's not that they're absolute but they
give you a clue if we look at age and we
look at microbes and we look at the
revolving door with our globe and we
this begin to understand that wow this
is perhaps an area of great research but
we need to have funding
the idea that I came forward with on the
biologic clock some time ago
was really enhanced by the Nobel Prize
in 2017
because it looked at Homo sapiens and it
looked at a clock approach to who we are
and looking at way back in 84 but given
again the award in 17 they found in
fruit flies a period gene and they
further experiments showed that plants
animals and humans adapt their
biological rhythms so that it's
synchronized with Earth's revolution day
and night but if you will a 12-hour
clock not a hundred year clock in the
microbial sense it could consider us
living a long time but in a day clock
and they determined that it was
attributable to a genetic encoded
protein called the period protein and
then as you can see it simulates
themselves at night and then is degraded
during the day but as a clock and the
idea was that this 24-hour clock
included multiple functions again like
what we talked about a moment ago a
common pathway a common pathway for
microbial interface with human and a
common pathway for human genomes
particularly on a synchronized 24-hour
clock and it says their results for
which the again the Nobel Prize they
said the multicellular organisms
including humans operate a 24-hour clock
which regulates functions including
humans bus behavior hormone levels sleep
template metabolism temperature
metabolism blood pressure heart rate in
reaction time it begins again a theme
how do you do these things all at once
so I combined the clocks in this
photograph or in this PowerPoint and you
can see in the outside are those
diseases that are attributable to often
microbes that are in a green yellow
orange or red category but you now must
include the human which is very much the
whole of genomic theory because that's
on a 24-hour clock and the synchrony of
the human clock the biologic clock with
the microbial clock certainly gives us
the ability now to begin to recognize
aging as a perhaps disease that would
allow us to look at synchrony between
two clocks that are part of Homo sapiens
this has really been addressed in in
the most important area and that is
where we have the most microbes as you
are well aware the gut and is there a
gut brain access of information transfer
because it's in fact this theme of two
of us working together is to work then
there's got to be a means of
communication and as shown here we have
a gut brain access which is then
recognized but it's very important to
recognize two waves you have a brain to
influence the intestinal microbiota and
in the other side of that on the right
hand side the ability of the microbiota
to influence brain and brain behavior
what is known to this point if you kind
of summarize all the points about this
this axis and about what it can do the
keys are I've highlighted in red it's
bi-directional
it's clearly less than functional when
we have gut dysbiosis or dysfunction of
the microbes and phyla within the GI
tract
it there isn't a modulation from the
brain of the gut microbiota and
bacterial products from the gut clearly
can have activity through cytokines and
gut hormones which are again each of
them elaborated in individual research
but you can get the idea from the slide
here then in looking at again in the
redzone Aging in dementia we can look at
the lower part of the spine to the left
the dementia associated with microbes
and their byproducts of metabolism their
functionality and their influence
through neuron transmission to the brain
as sort of again highlighted in the
middle addressing the actual schematics
of how in certain dementia these issues
can be further identified and studied
so
you really need to take sit back and
think about what we've already addressed
to the whole of genomic theory the idea
that we can in time measure our changes
in a clock being a biologic clock humans
24 hours or microbial clock life time is
chosen for a hundred years but then
again while running I happen to think
about again with my age in taxes and
benefits of banking I began to try to
draw a comparison of parallel what I
want you to do is is take a step back
think with me as I was addressing this
issue because banking has some terms
which allow us to address a common path
between banks and our microbial bank we
need to begin to recognize who is our
wet eyes our portfolio who is who are
the players within that portfolio who's
our our manager your money manager in
finances versus your microbial manager
in your gut and
can you leverage as is often talked
about in in banking your microbiome can
you leverage it to enhance disease
management recognizing if you will what
we said a moment ago functionality and
can you begin to really address who we
are relative to the use of pre and
probiotics which are again a feature
that are becoming very interested in
given their influence on the red quarter
or red zone of our clock
so here's my theme and I began to think
this in it you'll be surprised I hope
how this is really parallel to again
macro and micro on the left-hand side
are those things which I heard my banker
and my money manager began to say to me
and they begin to address on the
left-hand side a financial portfolio and
we begin to invest early in life because
we are looking towards retirement which
was all part of in the center of this
slide my wealth
but I began to think about the
vocabulary in the middle your
information manager the fact that you
wanted your portfolio in finances they
have some diversity you wanted to
recognize gains and losses as time
football and you wanted to leverage what
would help you as an advantage so that
you could have wealth in your retirement
and in your lifestyle now go to the
right hand side and you look at your
microbial Bank the gut manager as I'll
explain to you in a moment is a fungi
probably at least a lot of information
is pointing in that direction
your new means of addressing your
microbial
micro hollow by on gives you the fact of
measuring earhole of my own and you can
measure it with time particularly by
recognizing what have you lost and
that's why the blue arrow is going down
because does that address then a
therapeutic intervention where as Emma
left inside with finances we talked
about investment thinking what about
nutrition banking and what about its
influence on age associated diseases can
you feed your microbiota selectively to
address those organisms that might
influence your dementia and can you
selectively influence organisms which
have been lost with time but maybe would
help if you reestablish them as part of
your microbial bank that is your wealth
so I really develop this and I think
it's interesting again it helps me teach
but if you look at the left hand side
you look at the financial bank and if we
deal with over time income in stocks and
bonds and retirement strategy and it's
all again a recognizing that investment
helps us maintain our wealth in the
wealth of the definition of our health
and we talked about gains and losses if
you look at the other bank near
microbial Bank it really has been
influenced as we saw by the clocks by
your normal flora birth to death
by where you live your pets and animals
it's been influenced by your nutrition
by your diet and predictably by your age
all of those make your gut manager
incredibly important in response to the
good in the bed of illness and can you
in fact alter that if you understand who
your gut manager is and who is your
manager of addressing clear microbial
balanced features are and I never
thought about this but I began to think
about it again and with a lot of the
reading and in talking to investigators
who are beginning to address the gut
manager or your microbial manager of
your portfolio probably at least partly
associated with Saccharomyces boulardii
Seco my C's boulardii if you read the
literature has a lot of good things and
a lot of bad things that are being said
about it but the fact is it is a yeast
it's
generally in in a reasonably healthy
person non-pathogenic it is obviously
more often than not in about antibiotic
resistance and there are a number of
published articles particularly coming
out of France that in describe the
influence of a yeast in the
management of our microbial portfolio
really interesting information
so let's look at this a little bit
further because as we begin to look at
what happens to us over life and you
look at the left hand lower ornaments
looking at life and we look at
investments of numbers and we follow the
blue line up to retirement we are
generally in our financial planning what
was looking at that concept of numbers
that we can live with because your
financial planner or your broker has
established for you a limit a limit of
what you need to maintain your lifestyle
and those numbers are in the millions
generally today with our issues what
happens when the market dropped what
happened when you lose as happened more
recently 800 points in a day what
happens when you lose 400 points in a
day and how fast can you recover in the
financial situation and this diagram is
merely to point out that there are
numbers and there are schemes and there
are places they can address this but how
do you reach them and how do you recover
from this particular in event which we
all have to deal with it I want you to
translate that though and make it into a
parallel what about your microbial bank
what about your microbial portfolio so
again we start with if you look at the
lower right hand side a left hand side
and you look at the the the lines that
address mid age if you will what would
be our yellow quadrant on our microbial
clock and you follow it with time again
the blue line we'd like to reach an
agent microbiota which is compatible
with life in health not compatible with
diseases and not compatible with
particularly in aging and age-related
diseases and if you look again at the
numbers and you look in the upper left
hand side I've got listed bums 1 2 3 and
4 if you begin to sample what happens as
with new biome or any other DNA
microbial test what happens when we use
antibiotics either short term strep
throat you want wounds if you want or
long term diseases what do the bugs are
represented more often by phyla begin to
do as far as being eliminated and how
fast does it happen or how often does it
happen when these reoccur do they come
back or are they lost so this diagram
here begins to point out to you then
I'll again the lower left hand side it's
a loss of income your retirements and
your stocks and bonds and we talked
about the number about ten thousand
kilos again if they whoa
even though the microbial sign the
antibiotics interfering with our normal
growth pattern
c.difficile we spent hours talking about
the consequences of antibiotics and c
difficile and we can talk about for
hours about irritable ow irritable bowel
disease because these clearly do address
a
consequence then again it's interesting
to me the numbers if you lose about 10
to the 4 microbes it's always associated
with some consequence
microbiologically in collateral damage
and it's interesting that both of those
be it financial or microbial have sort
of the same range but I want you to
recognize that one of the key features
of either financial loss or microbial
loss is loss of diversity you will hear
it said in the banking environment
diversity is key you'll hear it from me
and other microbiologist that health is
associated with diversity the less
prevalent but lower that the more
prevalent but more frequent
microorganisms are those that really
established who we are and what our
health patterns are so think about this
days you address the next slide which
enhances what happens over time and that
is you lose your microbiota as you age
you have an infant microbiota you have
an agent microbiota and the key here is
can you acquire organisms to enhance or
replace that or are you simply as you
age never going to replace who you are
on the micro colevile manner dress is
the topic that I spent probably the last
15 years on really looking at and that
is can you leverage your microbiota
in reality we have developed a back to
health scheme and a partners for light
scheme which enhance us by going to the
references and allow us to saying to you
that where is overall there are a lot of
articles addressing health in a general
sense there are also a lot of articles
addressing specific diseases and if you
begin to look at who we and how we have
found the publications at this website
we've begun to look at those that can be
initiai
conditions the probiotics who the
microbes are there is an awful lot of
information the web that allows us to
begin to categorize probiotics and
prebiotics
into those that are specifically
targeted against the disease and they
would help in back to health for those
that are focused on partners for life
this is a diagram of a PowerPoint of a
lecture that I gave but I want you to
focus if you look at all of these
diagrams in colors within the human
represent on a 310 articles those that
are addressing topics obviously the
largest is the gut and you look at aging
we have reviewed
335 and the problem that I have with
these articles in either back to hell or
addressing partners for life is that a
lot of them are not of the quality that
we need to be getting so in looking at
this website in looking at probiotics
and prebiotics what you need to realize
is that we've looked at everything
relative to the condition at the top of
this bar the study type the strength
what kind of microbes they're looking at
and what probiotic was used and the
reality when we look at aging and our
red quadrant we recognize that there are
publications that deal with theories and
that those that deal with specific
diseases
unfortunately probably have what we
measured and have looked and have
categorized for you on this website a
not of a value that we would consider to
be yet publishable or at least it
published need to be verified by
additional studies and so you'll see the
strength of the articles are listed from
actually any through a but they're there
to help guide you to realize there's a
lot that yet needs to be clarified
the reason I put the word international
here is that
probably 60 to 70 percent of the
articles that are now on the law on the
link in the literature are probably from
sites outside the United States it does
not in any way suggest they're inferior
but it does suggest a focus that's been
addressed internationally first and then
in the u.s. second
this slide is perhaps one of the most
important because it also now in looking
at partners for life begins to address
that we can take a pill or a combination
of phyla or we can address a more
natural approach to
probiotics that are in fact in certain
kinds of foods and there's a lot being
published about this we simply don't
have the time to go over it but I want
you to realize that there is now a
natural selection that we may begin to
choose how we feed the microbiota of our
gut to address the bi-directional
interface which would have the capacity
to either re-establish rejuvenate
certain microbes and reduce certain
others that will help and again
partnering for life which is why the
title was chosen you can see here we
could feed selectively our microbiota
through microbial focused nutrition
addressing functionality which is what
we've already talked about so these
articles and aging lend themselves to
the fact that aging has an impact and
that can be addressed as a disease and
it has the ability to be altered by
looking at the micro hollow bio
I did a sabbatical at Cardiff University
in Wales a marvelous time and I had the
opportunity to at least hear about
people in Ireland and again a reference
here is psycho biotic revolution and it
addresses where it was performed and
that is the book authors the to enlist
it's here and the fact that it's in in
Cork Ireland again representing the
theme that I want you to recognize that
an awful lot of work is being done
outside of the US
so in summary in trying to put this all
into perspective I hope I have addressed
your your interest using puppets and
that you'll find much greater
clarification on the website but we'll
address the theme of who we are clocks
helping us to address a single pathway
both
microbial and Homo sapiens and that part
of the recognition now is that in aging
we can begin to address who we are
relative to options and it reinforces
the fact that our microbial partners our
my logic in are very important in our
aging process now you have to remember
that I started out a theme that I I want
to keep in mind we live in a microbial
world it is part of our wellness it's
part of the globe's wellness it's part
of animal wellness I
also want you to recognize as we go into
this incredible future there are some
limitations and when you read references
and look at articles such as I described
in a moment recognize that is on the
right hand side of this diagram we have
an awful lot yet about the microbiota
obviously that is still yet to be
defined and it will expand how this
interface of clocks and aging comes into
play
so is the aging a disease and is there a
microbial contribution I mean everybody
has to agree upon their own theme what I
hope that you will begin to recognize is
that we clearly need a new definition it
does address to tradition of society and
where we have been born and who is our
lineage but the reality is the new
definition fostering more research and
money in the ability to gather the
pharmaceutical impact in the aging is to
not say oh it's just an age thing we
want to clearly address those things
because there is a component that allows
us to have some impact that heretofore
hasn't been well as well as understood
so again the whole of genomic Theory
macro and micro the idea of putting who
we are together is that we really do
have an impact the microbes have an
impact and that the reality is in ageing
my other theme I want to convey to you
is that I believe we can age well longer
through microbiology again let me repeat
that we can age well longer through
microbiology but we have a lot to unmask
it's really it folks I have enjoyed this
I hope my stimulated you and I want to
make sure you have the idea that there
are references at my website I have to
thank my two financial managers and my
CPA because they've gone with me and
helped prepare this but the last slide
highlights someone that well-known
journals are in this case
textbooks that publications that I have
used
missing microbes by Blaser
that the brain maker by dr. Perlmutter
the more recent book is called cultured
these and the psycho biotic revolution
all have information that will enhance
your ability to understand the topic
lastly lastly please recognize
again my theme we live in a microbial
world microbes matter don't trash your
microbiota don't trash your micro biota
because stewardship of microbes is what
will allow us to live longer better and
with a health that is enjoyable not
where we have been I
love these slides I leave you with that
point thank you very much and I look
forward to your comment
thank you dr. Thomas for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder dr. Thomas will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we'll see you next
time goodbye